SNL honestly hasn't changed that much
what's really changed in you life
you so hard to the point that recurring
characters and famous actor is
struggling to read cue cards isn't what
it used to be SNL isn't for you anymore
you don't even know who most of the
musical guests are the weekend it's just
one guy not a fan my phones are frail
it's hard to admit that you're older the
gray pubes are coming in and that Beck
Bennett is this generation so Hartman oh
yeah let that sink in for a minute why
don't you
[Music]
this just sucks if you have to fight a
bunch of ninjas they all get knocked out
easily if you have to fight one by
itself it takes forever they're either
an empty promise or a lingering fart on
an elevator that needs to just slowly
fade away
[Music]
folks rant and rave about how
brilliantly bad the room is but honestly
it's just really boring an eccentric
rich foreign weirdo named Tommy who has
the same type of Eurotrash accent as
every man that lets a girl poop on his
chest and a porn is amusing for about
the first 15 minute and he sincerely
tried his cell he did a good job making
a movie as I would run in the obstacle
courses on American Ninja Warrior there
are truly bad movies like the 2015
Fantastic Four or Jupiter ascending that
cost hundreds of millions to make and
have an army of crew members and yet
they make no sense and contain zero fun
before we make fun of tommy was so in
the way he says you're tearing me up
Papa let's remember every six months a
bunch of British white guys pretend to
be Egyptian and scream a lot and that is
so much work I'm looking at you Noah
gods of Egypt Exodus everything else
I've seen on a plane when I'm alone
[Music]